وجد استطلاع دولي جديد أن معظم
الأشخاص في سبع دول بما في ذلك
الولايات المتحدة يقولون إنهم يشعرون بأنهم
مرتبطون اجتماعيًا لأن احتياطات كوفيد -19 تسهل
للحصول على المزيد حول هذا الاكتشاف الجديد ، المراسل الطبي لشبكة CNN
الدكتورة تارا نارولا معنا
الآن ، هذا مثير للاهتمام أخبرنا
كيف يشعر الناس  حسنًا ، بريانا ،
نعلم أن الاتصال البشري متصل
بحمضنا النووي ، إنه يساعدنا حقًا على
الازدهار ، إنه مهم للرفاهية ، وفي
الواقع يعتقد بعض الناس أن الأطباء
يجب أن يصفوا الاتصال الاجتماعي ،
لذا في هذه الدراسة تم وضعها أساسًا
بواسطة Gallup و meta الوالد
شركة فيسبوك قاموا باستطلاع آراء 2000
فرد فوق سن 15 في سبعة
بلدان مختلفة وبحثوا عن
مدى ارتباطهم الاجتماعي في
أعقاب الوباء وكانت البيانات
واعدة بالفعل وتأمل أنها أظهرت
أن معظم الناس بشكل عام أفادوا
بأنهم يشعرون اجتماعياً  مرتبطة في الواقع ، يمكنك
أن ترى مصر وفرنسا حقًا حوالي
80 في المائة من الأشخاص الذين أبلغوا عن
أمريكا  ليرة لبنانية في الوسط حوالي 70 في
المائة مع وجود المكسيك
والبرازيل في القاع ، ووجدوا أيضًا أن
واحدًا من كل ثلاثة أفاد بالفعل
أنه بحاجة إلى طلب المساعدة أو الدعم في
وقت ما في كثير من الأحيان أو إلى حد ما في الشهر الماضي ،
لذلك من الواضح أنه من الواضح أن هناك
بحاجة إلى أن نكون متصلين ، لكن
يبدو أن الوباء لم يعطل
قدرتنا على التكيف
كنوع ومواصلة هذا الارتباط المهم ،
لذا كيف
تبدو الروابط الاجتماعية للناس جيدًا هناك
حقًا كيف ومن من حيث
من الطريقة التي يبدو أن الاتصال الشخصي
هو الأكثر احتمالية على مستوى العالم ، وفي
أمريكا ، يمكنك رؤية الإحصائيات
حول 70 بالمائة كانت شخصيًا 68 عبر
الرسائل النصية و 59 عبر البريد الإلكتروني عبر الهاتف كانت حوالي
30 بالمائة وفي الواقع
كانت ألعاب الفيديو عبر الإنترنت حوالي 12 بالمائة في  شروط
أنواع أخرى من الاتصالات في
أجزاء أخرى من العالم أه وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي
نتحدث كثيرًا عن ثلث
العالم استخدم وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي على الإطلاق
باستثناء الهند ولكن في الواقع
ذكرت y أنه إذا استخدموا وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي ،
فقد استخدموا أيضًا أشكالًا أخرى من الاتصال ،
لذا لا يبدو أنها تحل محل تلك
الصلة البشرية الشخصية ، ما نوع
العوامل التي نتحدث عنها والتي
تتعلق بالشعور بالارتباط بأشخاص آخرين ،
لذا فإن ما وجدوه كان  كان
الزواج من أن يكون لديك أه أكثر ماليًا أو
أن يكون لديك دخل أكبر كان
مرتبطًا بكونك أقل وحدة
بالإضافة إلى أنك إذا كنت أكبر سنًا ، لذا فإن أولئك
الذين تزيد أعمارهم عن 65 عامًا ولديهم مجموعة اجتماعية أكبر
أو مجموعة أصدقاء أكبر
تميل إلى أن تكون مرتبطة بالشعور
بوحدة أقل  من المثير للاهتمام ما إذا كان لديك
وظيفة أم لا ولم تؤثر عليها ،
وأخيرًا إذا كنت تميل إلى الشعور بأن
الناس غير جديرين بالثقة وتعني أيضًا
أن هذا مرتبط بالشعور
بالوحدة أكثر ، نعم أعني أن هذا
منطقي جدًا ، أليس كذلك بالضبط
يا دكتور نارولا  من الواضح أن هذا
اتصال مهم جدًا هو دواء جيد ،
شكرًا لك أجنبيًا صحيحًا